the Church of What's Happening Now was
at one point one of the most popular
comedy podcasts in the game hosted by
Joey Diaz the church was putting up
dozens of million view episodes back
when watching podcasts on YouTube wasn't
nearly as popular as it is today this
show used to be a staple amongst comedy
fans everywhere there was nothing like
watching Joey Diaz interview the
funniest people in the world while
dosing himself and the show's producer
Lee sayat with thousands of milligrams
of THC a connection that fans have
missed dearly since their final episode
back in 2020 this podcast started
September 2nd 2012 it looks like Uncle
Joey and the flying Jew Lee sayet are
making it official once again obviously
there's a few reasons that this new show
won't be exactly like the old church Lee
Sayad is moving from producer to co-host
they'll be communicating via zoom and it
doesn't seem like they plan to bring on
any guests one thing however will remain
the same we're going in with the Tom
saguru capsules 200 mgram ABX don't
don't be showing up with a 50 that LE